lo que tenemos aquí es un círculo con
centro en el punto y tenemos una línea
que es tangente al círculo a la cual
vamos a llamar l así que a esta línea
vamos a darle nombre y es la línea l
verdad y vemos que el punto en donde la
línea tangente intersec a a la
circunferencia es el punto a verdad y
finalmente vamos a trazar el radio que
conecta el centro con el punto a lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es demostrar
que este radio este radio inter seca a
la línea l formando un ángulo recto
verdad este ángulo que se forma acá será
un ángulo recto es decir es de 90 grados
y lo primero que vamos a hacer es
convencernos de que este punto a es el
más cercano al punto pero que se
encuentra también sobre la línea él es
el punto más cercano
punto o que se encuentra sobre la línea
l así que vamos a demostrar eso vamos a
hacer esto vamos a demostrar
a demostrar que el punto
es el punto es el punto más cerca es el
punto sobre la línea l es el punto sobre
el más cercano más cercano al punto o
verdad que el punto recordemos es el
centro de nuestra circunferencia verdad
entonces te invito a que hagas una pausa
y trates de demostrar esta afirmación
por tu propia cuenta y luego lo haremos
juntos
muy bien entonces vamos a tomarnos otro
punto sobre la línea l puede ser este
punto puede ser este otro punto podría
ser este otro punto yo yo voy a tomar
este punto para que sea mucho más claro
y digamos que este punto vamos a darle
el nombre este punto va a ser el punto
ve muy bien entonces si nosotros
trazamos el segmento que conecta ao ya
ver no tenemos que primero hay que
llegar a la circunferencia verdad hasta
aquí llegamos a la circunferencia y
luego tenemos que trazar otro pequeño
pedazo verdad que va de la
circunferencia al punto b cierto
entonces si queremos ir de o del centro
o al punto b tenemos que trazar un radio
y luego un pequeño segmento más así que
dado que a se encuentra sobre la
circunferencia verdad la distancia de a
ao es justamente la digamos la medida de
este radio verdad
mientras que si tomamos cualquier otro
punto fuera que se encuentre sobre l
tendríamos que trazar un radio más otro
pequeño segmento por eso es que el punto
a es el más cercano al punto pero que
además se encuentra sobre la recta l muy
bien entonces no tenemos que aquí no
hemos terminado ahora hay que demostrar
que si tenemos un punto y una línea
verdad de este punto estás fuera de la
línea entonces el segmento que conecta a
ese punto con digamos el punto más
cercano que se encuentre sobre la línea
verdad entonces ese segmento es
perpendicular a la línea así que vamos a
demostrar esta nueva afirmación vamos a
demostrar
vamos a demostrar muy bien que el
segmento
el segmento que conecta este segmento
que conecta
conecta
un punto
un punto fuera de una línea verdad
recordemos que este punto el punto
estaba afuera de la línea fuera d
la línea vamos a llamarle así
simplemente fuera de la línea al punto
más cercano verdad que sería en el
ejemplo que teníamos anteriormente era
nuestro punto
al punto más cercano
más cercano sobre la línea sobre la
línea que teníamos sobre la
línea es perpendicular a la línea
entonces el segmento que conecta a un
punto fuera vamos a movernos tantito
verdad el segmento que conecta un punto
fuera de la línea y que por supuesto que
lo conecta al punto más cercano sobre la
línea es perpendicular a la línea
original es decir como visualizamos esto
bueno consideremos un segmento por aquí
una línea más bien tendremos una línea l
y digamos que tenemos un punto o que se
encuentra fuera de esa línea verdad
entonces fijémonos en el punto que se
encuentre sobre la línea l pero que sea
el más cercano al punto o verdad digamos
que es este de aquí entonces aquí
tenemos la línea o sería el punto el
punto fuera de la línea este punto nada
este este punto digamos morado de aquí
sería el punto más cercano sobre la
línea y ahora con verde trazamos el
segmento
que conecta a estos dos puntos verdad
entonces este segmento debe formar un
ángulo recto es decir un ángulo de 90
grados con la línea l verdad y lo voy a
demostrar por reducción al absurdo es
decir vamos a demostrarlo por
contradicción y cómo sería esto esto
sería esto sería suponiendo lo contrario
verdad vamos a suponer
supongamos supongamos que
que el segmento de ese segmento del que
hemos estado hablando verdad que conecta
que conecta al punto
conecta al
punto fuera de la línea
fuera d
línea
que conecta el punto fuera de la línea
al punto con el que conecta el punto
fuera de la línea con el punto más
cercano el punto más
cercano
cercano no es perpendicular a la línea
verdad aquí es en donde viene la
contradicción no es
perpendicular a la línea vamos a suponer
que el segmento que conecta al punto
fuera de la línea con el punto más
cercano no es perpendicular a la línea
es decir que este ángulo no es de 90
grados entonces vamos a visualizar esto
vamos a poner nuevamente nuestra línea l
vamos a poner nuestro punto y vamos a
decir que es el punto y digamos que el
punto
vamos a ponerlo aquí es el más cercano
al punto pero que no forma un ángulo de
90 grados cuando los conectamos verdad
entonces déjenme hacerlo con el mismo
color vamos a conectarlos con un
segmento y este ángulo no es de 90
grados verdad no es
90 grados verdad es decir que no es
recto ahora si suponemos esto como es
una demostración por contradicción vamos
a encontrar otro punto sobre el que sea
más cercano ao verdad aunque a supusimos
que era el más cercano vamos a poder
encontrar uno todavía más cercano verdad
lo cual contradice el hecho de que a era
el más cercano a o sobre la línea de
verdad entonces como lo hallamos bueno
vamos a construir un triángulo
rectángulo muy bien vamos a construir
este triángulo rectángulo
una línea aquí ponemos un ángulo recto
aquí verdad y ahí tenemos un triángulo
rectángulo ahora vamos a darle el nombre
a estos lados para que sea más claro
digamos a este lado vamos a llamarle a a
esta base vamos a llamarle b déjenme
hacerlo incluso con otro color vamos a
llamarle a este b y a este lado verde
pues vamos a llamarle c muy bien
entonces qué es lo que sabemos bueno
podemos utilizar aquí el teorema de
pitágoras verdad el teorema de pitágoras
nos dice que a cuadrada a cuadrada más b
cuadrada
debe ser igual a
cuadrada muy bien entonces pensemos un
poquito si el valor de b fuera 0
entonces tendríamos que a cuadrada s
cuadrada y por lo tanto a tendría que
ser igual a c pero como ve esto si es un
triángulo de esto no es un triángulo
degenerado de verdad esto sí tiene área
entonces el valor de b es positivo
quiere decir que a tiene que ser un poco
más chico que se para que a cuadrada más
b cuadrada sea igual a se cuadrada
verdad entonces de aquí podemos concluir
que a es más chico que se es menor que
se verdad entonces este punto que
acabamos de encontrar este que nos forma
el triángulo digamos o de a verdad ese
punto de ahora resulta ser más cercano
ao que lo que ya era a verdad porque la
distancia desde hago es a y la distancia
de juego ajá a mayúscula para que no
haya complicaciones s
es mayor que a minúscula verdad entonces
aquí hemos llegado a la contradicción
supusimos que el punto a era el más
cercano sobre el verdad y que el
segmento entre o ya no formaba con l un
ángulo de 90 grados
si así fuera podemos encontrar este
punto de que es más cercano al punto que
ya de lo que ya era el punto a lo cual
es una contradicción verdad entonces el
segmento eso significa que el segmento
tiene que ser perpendicular a la línea
verdad entonces si nos regresamos por
ejemplo a nuestro caso del círculo
verdad aquí tenemos el segmento que
conecta a un punto fuera de una línea y
que lo conecta con el punto más cercano
sobre esa línea entonces tiene que ser
perpendicular verdad este este segmento
tiene que ser perpendicular a la línea
verdad así con todo esto podemos
garantizar que el radio que une
el centro con el punto donde la línea
tangente toca la circunferencia es
perpendicular a dicha línea